last week on this show i mentioned in
passing something that i called the
michael knowles public health protection
pledge what i said was i would not vote
for any candidate for federal office in
2022 who did not sign a pledging ring to
two things one subpoena and investigate
anthony fauci for his incompetence and
deception and potential corruption on
kovid and two
zero out his salary may you can't fire
him exactly if you're in congress but
you can have the power of the person
zero out that salary so those two
promises
had to be met in order to get my vote
and i said you shouldn't vote for people
who refuse to sign on to that either so
then a congressional candidate beau
heinz came out and he said hey michael i
love the pledge i had my staff write it
up and i signed on to it i said well
that's awesome man so i posted it
a bunch of dozens of other congressional
candidates signed on as well
but there weren't incumbents where were
the sitting members of congress very
often incumbent politicians don't want
to sign on to pledges because they don't
want to have to be held accountable so i
said okay well we'll see just you know
look this is the bare minimum i think
for any republican running for federal
office if you don't realize what a
danger
dr fauci is and everything dr fauci
represents and the power he wields if
you don't recognize what a threat that
is to self-government then you're
useless i'm not going to vote for you
you don't deserve our vote
i get a message
yesterday two days ago from congressman
paul gosar very strong conservative
rock ribbed kind of republican willing
to stand up he says michael
i've just uh introduced
the michael knowles public health
protection pledge into congress as an
official house resolution here we have
house concurrent resolution
71
expressing the sense of congress that
congress should issue a subpoena to dr
anthony fauci and reduce the salary of
the director of the national institute
of allergy and infectious diseases and
chief medical advisor to the president
resolved by the house of representatives
the senate concurring it is the sense of
congress that one congress should issue
a subpoena to dr fauci with the intent
of investigating a the extent of any
corrupt activities to which he may be
party with respect to covet 19 and b the
deception misinformation and numerous
lies reported to congress and the
american people throughout the coveted
pandemic
and two the speaker of the house of
representatives should reinstate the
holman rule the holman rule is the rule
that allows congress to go in and zero
out salaries of particular bureaucrats
uh reinstate the home enroll and provide
expeditious consideration of legislation
that reduces the salary of
aforementioned dr fauci to zero dollars
and zero cents here it is baby made it
all the way to congress this is the
federal public health protection pledge
it is there your congressman can
co-sponsor this right now i want you to
go
whatever platform you're listening on
whatever platform you're watching on
go out tag your member of congress email
your member of congress tell him to sign
on as a co-sponsor and together we can
rid ourselves of that power mad
dishonest incompetent technocrat tyrant
anthony fauci i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from chuck silver who
says joe is just cleaning out hunter's
bedroom closet and doesn't know what to
do with all the crack pipes so he's
giving them away that's you know it's
recycling it's very environmentally
friendly maybe this is part of the green
agenda too who knows who knows we people
have a lot of things in their home to
protect not just whatever was in that
closet but lots of other things to
protect especially your family which is
why you got to go check out ring you all
know about the ring video doorbell you
know because i've told you about it for
many years that's that amazing doorbell
where you can see and speak to whoever
is at your doorstep whether you're in
the house whether you're at the office
whether you're on a beach on the other
side of the world did you know that ring
also makes an alarm
ring alarm is an award-winning home
security kit with available professional
monitoring best of all you can easily
install it yourself
i find it so simple that even i
can do it which is really really amazing
you get notified right on your phone
whenever anything is detected i really
really really like ring it not only
makes me feel safe when i'm away and
sweet little lisa and the baby are home
but even when we're all away and you're
not just protecting your home against
the bad guys you're protecting your home
against flood freeze and fire too head
on over right now get rings
award-winning professional monitoring go
to ring.com
knowles k-w-l-e-s that is ring.com
knowles to get a great deal on a ring
alarm home security kit today ring.com
knowles
the crack pipe story is the single
funniest political story
i have seen in years
the fact that the government
is promising
to advance racial equity by giving out
crack pipes
is just so freaking funny i can't handle
it it has become a major political
firestorm for the biden white house a
lot of biden officials now have had to
come out issue clarifications have
emergency press conferences let's check
in right now uh with the director of the
department of health and human services
you did magic markers what you think
this is some kind of crown no take that
cap off and sniff it
and you'll be high
these little ones are 10 and 11 years
old
you
you know what dog food tastes like do
you it tastes just like it smells
delicious
there there he is the secretary of
health and human services tyrone
diggins
it makes sense now the policy now makes
sense i who we could never have guessed
that the secretary would be a crackhead
himself uh the other biden officials
secretary xavier becerra
other science advisors at the white
house they've come out and they've said
no this no no crack pipes
but the wording is so careful here
the white house
denied that
there was ever a policy to give out
crack pipes the secretary of health and
human services was a little more careful
because the fact is there was a policy
to give out crack pipes
but now they obviously don't want that
policy so he said quote
no federal funding will be used directly
or through subsequent reimbursement of
grantees to put pipes in safe smoking
kits so he's not denying that there was
going to be federal funding for the crag
pipes he's just saying look now
we are not going to have there will not
be crack pipes in the crack smoking kits
which raises a question
how
does the government expect the
crackheads to smoke the crack
without the crack pipes if the if the
point of the policy is to give out safe
smoking kits
how are you gonna smoke if you don't
have the single most important
instrument for smoking
i mean that sincerely what it shows you
is
that they're just scrambling right now
they don't have an explanation
the other ways they could i guess they
could include rolling papers i don't
think you smoke crack with i don't know
i don't have experience with this but
even if it were rolling papers you you
don't need
rolling papers as a matter of public
health
right it's not as though people are
going around sharing rolling papers
once you use the rolling papers they're
gone they're burnt up so it's you
wouldn't wouldn't be that they could be
giving tobacco leaves to roll big fat
blunts i guess i don't again i don't
know this is not my area of expertise
but again that would burn up
they could give out bongs i don't know
do you smoke crack in a bomb well that
would be a pipe too and they're saying
there are no pipes
in the safe
how can you call it
a smoking kit safe or otherwise
if it doesn't include the thing that you
need to smoke
this this smoking kits include all sorts
of other things as well but but those
other things all kind of relate back
to the pipe
so they're very confused over there at
the white house
the most incredible thing about this
whole crackhead episode
is how desperately
all of the different facets of the
political establishment by which i'm i'm
including the media i'm including big
tech here obviously the government how
they're all working together
to try to tamp down this story because
it's generating tons of bad press tons
of bad press from us from the
conservatives over this tons of bad tons
of jokes from ordinary people about this
my wife right now my wife is is uh
traveling and seeing her family she's at
a hotel right now she said this morning
she walks outside and she hears one
hotel worker say to another hotel worker
hey man you hear we're all about to get
some free crack pipes in the mail
and they're all
all laughing about this so biden and his
entire administration is a laughingstock
the
establishment is going into overdrive to
try to tamp this down
notably
the fact checking website snopes
fact checking is it's not actually fact
checking it's just a way that the left
rebranded leftist opinion columns maybe
10 or 11 years ago to try to make them
absolutely incontrovertible so it would
have just be regular left wing opinion
columns but this is a fact check
fact check republicans are wrong about
everything 10 pinocchios facts right so
snopes
adjudicates the claim the claim is in
early 2022 the biden administration
endeavored to advance racial equity by
distributing crack pipes to users
mostly false snopes says okay what's
true what's false snope says what's true
in 2022 a u.s department of health and
human services substance abuse harm
reduction grant did require participants
to provide safer smoking kits to
existing drug users
huh
okay so it sound
sounds like the crack pipe thing that's
true but okay it goes on and says in
distributing the grants priority would
be given to applicants serving
historically underserved communities
okay so however okay what's false what's
false is this was just one of around 20
components of the grant program and far
from its most prominent or important one
despite being the primary focus of
outraged news reports
hold on so you're telling me it's true
it's true that biden was sending crack
pipes to people
but but biden was also doing other
things
so therefore it's not
true that but you just said it's true
that he did that we're not saying he
didn't ever do any other things i'm sure
he had breakfast too we're not but he
did this
right okay what about the racial equity
part
the pr well snope says what's false the
purpose of the program was to reduce
harm and the risk of infection among
drug users not to advance racial equity
although that was a secondary
consideration
so you're saying that was the purpose of
it
the two claims here were biden's sending
out crack pipes and
he's doing it to advance racial equity
and you're saying what's true all of
that what's false none of that it's all
just completely true therefore we
conclude mostly false 75 pinocchios
please republicans stop
making fun of us they just the
establishment needs some relief and when
you need relief i would strongly
recommend you check out relief band did
you know that one out of three americans
regularly suffer from nausea we have all
experienced that horrible feeling
whether it's in the backseat of a car
staring at your phone after one too many
coca-colas on a night out with friends
or even just the anxiety of a workday
you've got to check out relief band it's
the number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wrist band that has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and a lot more the
technology was originally developed over
20 years ago in hospitals to relieve
nausea from patients now through a
relief band it's available to everyone
the product is 100 drug-free non-drowsy
provides all-natural long-lasting relief
with zero side effects for as long as
needed they just released their newest
model relief band sport the sport is
waterproof has an extended battery life
can even attach to your apple or android
watch go get it right now
they make a great gift any time of year
getting exclusive offer just for our
listeners if you go to reliefband.com
use promo code knowles get 20 off plus
free shipping and a no questions asked
30 day money back guarantee best offer
you'll find for relief band anywhere got
to use my code
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com promo code
knowles for 20 off plus free shipping
it's unbelievable
to look at i hope people take a
screenshot of of this page on snopes
they'll need to because they've already
changed it it was
not only were we in a position where the
biden policy was the mockery of the
entire country but then the desperate
attempts by the establishment to
alternately deny and defend the policy
right on the one hand they say this
isn't happening it's not true but on the
other hand yes it's also it's great it's
good it's very important to to do that
uh
that that became the mockery too and so
snopes had to just completely
completely change course and they did
they now say it's outdated
this is the new snopes conclusion here
outdated context after a wave of grossly
misleading news coverage in february
2022 the u.s health and department of
health and human services stipulated
that federal funding would not be used
to include pipes in safe smoking kits as
part of substance abuse harm reduction
program this newly stipulated detail was
not originally available
yeah because it wasn't true then they
changed their mind and backtracked
because it was a laughingstock meaning
the assertions made in a first wave of
coverage had become outdated they're not
outdated they're not
they're not the claim is in early 2022
the biden administration tried to
advance racial equity by sending out
crack pipes that remains true
even though biden ditched the ridiculous
laughingstock policy that still happened
you can't deny that that happened snopes
while they're trying to deny that it
happened
but it did it's so funny if you read the
original snopes report
after they say this wasn't really true
they then go to defend the policy they
say it's perfectly logical
as a matter of harm reduction
to send crack pipes to drug addicts
i don't know what definition of logical
their work it doesn't seem logical to me
to send crackheads crack pipes but they
say no it's great it's not it's both not
happening and it's awesome that it's
happening and now they say it never
happened at all forget about it why are
they doing this
a lot of people are scratching their
heads why why walk into this why is
snopes tying itself into these these
illogical pretzels to try to defend and
deny this biden policy there's a real
purpose
it's not just because they really like
joe biden it's not just because there
are leftists at snopes
the reason they're doing this is to
censor conservatives who are making fun
of the policy
because snopes and other leftist
fact-checking websites
are used by social media
directly through the algorithms of these
social media companies
to suppress
what they call misinformation
which in this case is just called
information just
truthful information about the policy
so what happens is
if you post on instagram or facebook or
twitter or google or whatever if you
post about this policy
and snopes has come in there and said
this is a false claim
yeah we acknowledge it's all true but we
rate it mostly false then social media
companies will suppress what you're
writing
if a website if a news website like the
daily wire
publishes articles
about
this policy this very real policy
and snopes comes in and says no even
though everything they say is true we
write it mostly false the website's
going to get dinged the website's going
to show up less on search engines the
website's going to get much less play on
social media the website's traffic is
going to collapse the website's money is
going to it's just a way
to censor and suppress conservatives and
so we can laugh at them
we'd say oh snopes you look like a bunch
of idiots just carrying water saying
things that are obviously untrue but
who's getting the last laugh on this
it's actually the left it's actually the
democrats are getting the last laugh
because they are pretty effectively
suppressing conservatives on the
internet speaking of censorship on the
internet
you know
donald trump on very sadly was kicked
off of social media while he was still
the duly elected sitting president of
the united states these big tech
oligarchs censored him just booted him
from the public square and so we don't
get all of his
charming and wonderful tweets all the
time what he is doing now is releasing
press releases that then all the rest of
us tweet around and the press releases
read like tweets so trump has weighed in
on this issue which is obviously close
to his heart social media censorship
he's weighed in on the censorship of joe
rogan
he says quote
joe rogan is an interesting and popular
guy
but he's got to stop apologizing to the
fake news
and radical left maniacs and lunatics
how many ways can you say you're sorry
joe just go about what you do so well
and don't let them make you look weak
and frightened
that's not you and it never will be
i have said for a long time donald trump
is a poet i don't i don't even mean that
as a joke or hyperbole he has a very
good sense of language he does
when he said he's got the best words
folks
he was sort of right
he's a branding genius the phrase make
america great again which he borrowed
from reagan but people had forgotten the
phrase is a very effective
slogan make america great again this is
generally
strong saxon words make america you know
his name the country
great again it's just it gives you an
image and here when he says the radical
left maniacs and lunatics it just paints
a picture for you when donald trump
would would talk about low energy jeb
little marco all these would paint a
picture for you and so that's what he's
doing here he's saying joe don't give in
these people are nuts they're insane
they're fringy don't give it don't be
frightened don't be weak that's not you
don't do it
unfortunately though
joe rogan does not appear to want to
become the new
conservative standard-bearer
okay he doesn't need to be the guy he's
never styled himself a conservative he's
a comic who is on the left
he was a bernie sanders supporter so
okay that's fine you don't want to be
the conservative standard bearer i get
it i get it
i
sort of thought there was a chance he he
might be
if for no other reason than because he
saw how corrupt the liberal
establishment is
he saw when they just when cnn lied
about him and said that he was eating
horsty warmer and he said i'm obviously
not doing that what are you how are you
telling these egregious lies about me
without any shame whatsoever so i was
kind of hoping but it's probably not
going to happen rogan had been offered a
100
million dollar contract
by rumble a conservative outlet
to leave spotify
this is the letter from the ceo of
rumble
said look i get it one of the reasons
rogan's trying to save the spotify deal
is because spotify's paying him 100
million dollars it's a lot of money so
you know easy for you and i to say that
maybe we would leave but you know what
about rogan he's got to feed his family
he could feed a small army with with 100
million dollars
so rumble comes in they say we're gonna
we're gonna match it dollar for dollar
we're gonna match it 100 million bucks
over four years this is a totally legit
deal if you want it or not i thought it
was the perfect offer
it would have allowed rogan
to
be
be the best version of the joe rogan
show which is
uncensored just conversations with
everybody
really engaging content
but he said look spotify stuck by me
sort of and so i'm not i'm not going to
do that and moreover if he had gone to
rumble it would have it would have put
him much more
in a
clearly defined right-wing space he
doesn't want to do that apparently
too bad
would have been great they're going to
continue to censor him they're already
censoring what over a hundred of joe's
episodes they're already putting
disclaimers and warnings on his episodes
with conservatives not on the ones with
liberals just on the ones with
conservatives so that's too bad i i wish
him well i hope that he can survive this
i hope he can maintain the freedom of
his show
but i'm i'm skeptical i'm skeptical if
if the libs can rewrite the crackhead
policy
if the libs can censor donald trump the
duly elected sitting president
they've got a lot of power okay and it
would be it would be a shame for the joe
rogan show
this kind of unique
hugely successful show to just become
another
another podcast that falls in line with
with what the establishmentarians tell
us to do it would be it would be sad if
it were to get censored
now some things should be censored and
one of those things that should be
censored
is an adidas ad that came out yesterday
took over the internet got everyone
talking about it which i guess was the
point i'm talking about it we're all
talking about it
it was an ad that just showed
lots and lots of boobs so i saw this saw
this going around they said oh adidas is
just showing a lot of breasts dozens of
breasts in their ad and i
i did not search for it i did not look
at the ad because i thought
look if i look at this this could be an
occasion of sin
right if i'm going to look at this ad
that i'm being told is just a bunch of
boobs then that might
arouse
impure thoughts in my mind that i might
willfully be enter i don't want to do
that okay that would be i don't want an
occasion of sin because i i looked at
this adidas ad but then look i had to
cover it everyone was talking about it
so i said okay i'll look at it very
quickly
i am
happy
maybe i'm maybe happy to report
the ad is not an occasion of sin
because the
the picture the pictures don't look
great okay i don't i don't want to be
offensive to the models and it's not
they didn't
the the
the modeling community is not sending
their best the adidas ad
was physically about as unattractive as
an ad could be
they they i think they need to hire a
new advertising team over there when you
want to hire new employees i would
recommend you go check out ziprecruiter
according to the latest research 90
percent of employers plan to make
enhancing the employee experience a top
priority in 2022 a happy workplace is
key to attracting and keeping great
employees
we're talking about focusing on company
culture we're talking about allowing
more flexibility in work schedules in my
own case ben has promised that he will
send me a paycheck now which is great
that would be a great change
of of course if you need to add more
employees to your team there is
ziprecruiter their matching technology
helps you find the right people for your
roles fast right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
knowles wlas ziprecruiter uses powerful
matching technology to find those
candidates for your job then it
proactively presents the candidates to
you we're not just talking about
throwing spaghetti at the wall here
we're talking about going out getting
you the best candidates right now
you can find the right employees for
your workplace with ziprecruiter try it
for free
at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com slash knowles that is
ziprecruiter.com
k-w-l-e-s
zip recruiter the smartest way to hire
you know tonight
is a huge night for the daily wire why
not only is it the world premiere of our
first original film shut in but we will
also be releasing two new teaser
trailers for new movies that we've got
coming out this year it's not just we
did our first movie run hide fight we've
now got this movie shut in we got a lot
more movies coming okay we could not be
more excited to be making good on our
promise of bringing you real
entertainment we really hope you tune in
check out the trailer for shut in
now
you
must pay
your daughter
she's very pretty
i'm scared
the movie premieres tonight february
10th at 9 pm eastern 8 pm central over
the daily wire youtube channel after
this month's episode of backstage which
starts at 7 30 eastern 6 30 central make
sure to click the link in the
description and turn on the notification
bell so you do not miss it we will be
right back with a lot more
adidas the sneaker company
and i guess they i assume they make bras
or sports bras or otherwise this ad
would make no sense they are now
advertising their product
by
by publishing
intentionally ugly looking
boobs
uncensored you know free the nipple just
totally out there
on the one hand what's good is that it's
not i don't think it's going to arouse
lustful thoughts in anybody either
not that it's not i don't think so i
would bet i would bet a lot of money on
that but on the downside it is
participating in something
that i'm noticing pretty much every
company participating in now
which is
a
fascination with
ugly things
i'm not even i'm not saying these women
are ugly even but the photos are
intentionally trying to make them look
as ugly as they can
they're not in in the old days
back when i was a young whippersnapper
growing up
models were really really hot
you look around at billboards and it was
the hottest women you could possibly see
in magazines in all advertisements
in fact editors would go in and take
already extremely beautiful women
and then try to touch them up and
airbrush and do this and that to make
them look even more beautiful
companies sold their products by
associating the products with beauty
now
it's almost always the opposite they're
always trying to associate their
products with ugliness
with deformities
with grotesque images with obscenity
with it's a it's a cult of ugliness
it's i guess a
a an analogy here would be how
in in the olden days when we studied
history we would try to or literature
for that matter so much of education
would be focused on beautiful things
right you would focus on good things
not
to the entire exclusion of bad things
and ugly things but you would you would
focus on good things and on beauty now
it's always the opposite all you ever
focus on in history are the sins and the
imperfections and the failures all you
ever focus on in literature is ugliness
and fallenness and anti-heroes that's
all you're getting in the culture
there's no it's all just
it's all just yuck
that's all we're getting
this is a big problem in our you know it
was one of the best things donald trump
did in his presidency
though it probably won't have much of an
effect he signed an executive order
saying that we need to make federal
buildings beautiful again
the federal buildings in washington dc
for much of our nation's history were
really beautiful and they were built in
a beautiful style of architecture and
they were big and grand and
awe-inspiring and now they're ugly
they're just gross they're brutalist and
they're intentionally incongruous and
they're just ugly and they make you feel
small
in new york in the old penn station you
would walk in you'd feel like a king it
was huge it was beautiful it was in
these beauties beautiful bozar style
then
they knocked it down
and and built up madison square garden
and the new penn station makes you feel
like a little rat it makes you feel
small and dirt and you don't it's not
good it's not good when you have a
society living in ugliness all the time
but we've lost a sense of what's
beautiful great example of this a a
russian security guard
just got in trouble
for
allegedly destroying a million dollar
painting
it was a million dollar painting of
of these blank faces
like an ugly drawing
that a three a third grader could do
and there were blank faces and the board
security guard took his pen and he put
little eyes on on the blank faces
but it destroyed the value of the
painting was worth a million dollars and
now the painting is worth nothing
the security guard did not destroy the
painting
because the painting was already ugly it
was already modern art
you can you can tell me that um
you know a urinal in the middle of a
museum is really beautiful art you can
tell me that it's really really valuable
but it's not beautiful it's hard even to
call it art it's not it's ugly
it's stupid
it's pointless and so much of our art
now is not
beautiful in the security guard's
defense how was he supposed to know that
this
this drawing that an eight-year-old
could do
was worth a million dollars because
people in that marketplace have lost
their minds
how was he supposed to you couldn't tell
the difference
between an elementary school art project
and this million dollar painting
i promise you
that this security guard if he were
guarding the sistine chapel
would not have been confused
this security guard i don't think that
if he were
guarding the mona lisa he would have
gone in and drawn a mustache on the mona
lisa he would have recognized i suspect
that these are beautiful things these
are great works of art
but the stupid million dollar doodle in
the russian museum i don't know i'm not
saying that if you're a security guard
you should probably not be drawing on
the walls to begin with
but there is a real difference between
beauty and ugliness
and we used to have a standard that
would recognize beauty and we would
pursue it and we would encourage it in
our public spaces and in our private
spaces and now we don't now we do
completely the opposite
and it is
it actually does have something to do
with the degradation of society when you
don't when you don't have a society
looking up being filled with awe
imbued with beauty then you're going to
have an ugly society i was i was walking
around france some time ago i was in a
little towns in france and you go in i
got so sad because you're you're in the
countryside of france and you go into
these churches
and they're they're not cathedrals
they're not even basilica's real they're
just churches but they're big and
they're beautiful and they're huge and
they're awe-inspiring and they're and
they make sense
and and
you think why don't we have those
why do we only build ugly things
why did we give up on that
really really sad speaking of standards
some good news coming out of congress
for the first time in a while
republicans are dropping their support
of the fairness for all act this is one
of these ridiculously named
bills what what the fairness for all act
would effectively do is completely
redefine sex and obliterate the
distinction between men and women and it
was not the democrats supporting this
bill it was the republicans
you see the democrats are supporting
something called the equality act and
what the equality act says is we're
going to redefine sex
for purposes of civil rights for
purposes of federal law we're going to
say that sex is we're going to protect
sexual orientation
and gender identity
so if you in any way suggest that a man
is not really a woman you're violating
federal law
and and what do the republicans do
what's their bold strong brash answer to
this insane radicalism
they say hey hey hey hey hey
we'll go along with all of that just
give us a few exceptions
and that's what the fairness for all
actors the fairness for all act did
exactly the same thing that the equality
act did the fairness for all act
supported by republicans
said
we're going to obliterate the
distinction between men and women and if
you
say that men are not women and women are
not men then
if you act on that then you're violating
federal law except certain religious
organizations can get a pass
not good enough guys not good enough
with republicans like that who needs
democrats
so the good news is elise stefanik who
replaced liz cheney as the gop caucus
chairman
she's just pulled her support for the uh
bill
every other republican co-sponsor should
as well this thing should be deader than
disco it is totally unacceptable
if
any republican is still supporting this
monstrosity of a law that republican
should be booted out of office period
punto ebas that's just completely
completely unacceptable
some republicans have not been confused
on this some republicans have been right
on this issue from the beginning i'm
looking down at my man ron desantis down
in florida who as far as the governors
are concerned is really leading on these
issues ron desantis is now backing a
bill in florida that will prevent
teachers from indoctrinating little kids
into crazy radical sexual ideologies and
the left is furious about this the left
is calling it the don't say gay bill and
they are turning all of their fire up to
and including the white house on this
law
this is not the only bill or the only
effort we're seeing across the country
to
to really
regulate what students can or cannot
read what they can or cannot learn and
most troubling who they can or cannot be
as i think you saw in the president's
treat tweet
it's cruel it's harmful um
and uh you know it is certainly
something that is not helping uh you
know young people who are members of the
lgbtqi plus community who are already
vulnerable already being bullied i think
the president felt it was important to
speak out
but in terms of specific actions uh you
know we're going to continue to voice
our strong views on this it's
significant the president did that and
if there's any additional steps i'll let
you know
so what does the bill actually do not
what jensaki says it does what does it
actually do
it orders that schools quote may not
encourage classroom discussion about
sexual orientation or gender identity in
primary schools
or in a manner that is not age
appropriate or developmentally
appropriate for students
we are talking not about whether 18 year
olds are allowed to say the word gay the
word gay obviously does not appear in
the bill so the bill does not say gay
we're talking about
elementary school students specifically
we're talking about kindergarten to
third grade
do you think
that teachers
should be allowed to tell your
five-year-old son johnny that he's
really jane
do you think
that teachers should be allowed without
your consent completely absent your
input to tell your five-year-old son
that he's really your daughter
or not
the key here to her
attack on this bill is she said it's an
attack on on allowing these kids to be
who they are
lgbtq lmnop youth
but we're talking about five-year-olds
to eight-year-olds
allow
the five-year-old
to be
a pansexual transsexual lesbian demis
what
sick
nonsense are you talking what are you i
know what you're smoking you must be
smoking crack because that's the policy
from the white house now and you would
have to be smoking crack to believe this
stuff
it's it's actually
an important question
it says you're telling me
you're telling me floridians you're
telling me rhonda santos
that
five-year-olds should not be allowed to
be
the transsexuals that they are no what
is that issue jen
is
what people are that's what it comes
down to when i when i say all politics
ultimately is religious this is what i'm
talking about
when we're talking about politics
ultimately we're going to get down to
what is a human person what is our
relationship to each other what is our
relationship to our country and what is
our relationship to our maker
and the question is that what are we
in in my view
we are body and soul inextricably linked
while we're here on earth and our souls
and our
bodies both matter and they've got
something to do with one another
in
this by the way is not some crazy fringe
radical view this is what every single
person on earth
in our civilization thought for pretty
much the whole history of our
civilization
until five minutes ago
the view that gensake is espousing and
just assuming to be true is that our
bodies have nothing to do with who we
are who we really are has absolutely
nothing to do with our physical selves
that is
a false view it's an insane view and
it's an extremely novel
radical view
but she's just assuming that and what
ron desantis is doing he's not even
defining who we are in in this law he's
just saying look
we're not going to introduce these crazy
radical new insane ideologies to
five-year-olds we're gonna wait until
they turn nine okay we're gonna wait
until they turn 10 and then they can
hear all this
lunatic stuff and i guess come to their
own conclusions
frankly i wish the bill went further i
wish the bill outlawed the teaching of
transgenderism period because
transgenderism is a delusion it's fake
it's a false anthropology it's a false
account of what a human being is and we
shouldn't educate people in that because
we'll be educating them in falsehood and
that's no education at all that's not
going to liberate you as education is
supposed to do it's going to enslave you
to fantasy
so
what desantis is doing i applaud it it's
a good first step we've got to go
further folks look how far the left has
gone they're whining and crying and
complaining that we're not allowed to
we're not allowing them to trans the
five-year-olds the five-year-olds that's
that's the degree of radicalism here
i think maybe we've got to turn up our
confidence a little bit too i think
maybe we've got to turn up our moral
clarity a little bit too because schools
are shaping kids views not just of
history and reading writing and
arithmetic but of themselves and of sex
new report out
40 of gen z identify as lgbtq
there's a study just came out of barna
barnes i guess it came out a little
while ago but it's making the rounds
again because of these new laws
30 percent of millennials identify as
lgbtq whatever the rest of the letters
are
forty percent of zoomers the younger
generation identify as lgbtq whatever
the rest of the letters are
when you just look at the general
population
identification with lgbtq elementop
is six percent
so how did we go
and it's much lower among certain age
groups so how do we go from six percent
to forty percent
what the
left used to tell you is look you're
just born this way you're born this way
you can never change your sexual desires
or orientation or then later gender
right you can't change it
now they now it's a little different
because they're saying not only can you
change your sexual desires you can
change your whole sex if you're a man
you can become a woman but so it's a
little bit confused
but the one thing we we were told
is that none of this has anything to do
with culture none of this has anything
to do with nurture none of this has
anything to do with education
you can't change who we it's just who we
are is just deep deep deep down
so my question then is how did we go
from six percent to 40 percent
either
alex jones is right and there's just
something in the water and they're not
only turning the frickin frogs gay but
they're turning everyone else gay too i
it's either that
oh and actually he was right about the
frog so i don't know all right i'll uh
withhold judgment
or what i think is probably more likely
culture obviously matters and culture
shapes
the way and education most importantly
shapes the way we view the world
shapes the way we view ourselves it even
helps to shape our desires
right little kids desire to just eat
cookies all the time and have no
self-control
and then through education as they grow
and mature their tastes change their
desires change and their discipline
changes
as well
or at least it used to now we put
education completely in the opposite
direction
to uh not to cultivate the higher things
in the rational will but to cultivate
all sorts of crazy beyond sex just to
cultivate all sorts of crazy crazy sorts
of desires
if that is the case
that the culture and the education
shapes it
then obviously we've got to have a say
in education
then obviously if the if education
could
convince a half a generation of of
americans that they're not the sex that
they say that they are
they're they're not the sex that they
actually are and they're a com
completely different sex or their sexual
desires are all kind of kooky if it can
do that then it can go in the other
direction too can it
the
i'm actually not even all that surprised
by these very high numbers 30 40 percent
what this tells me is that young people
are right now as they always are
searching for meaning they're searching
for truth they're very confused they
don't have all the answers and they're
just trying to grab on to the things
that are deeper not merely the physical
things of this world but what's it all
about what are we here for what am i you
know all the questions that young people
ask
and they used to
have those questions answered by by true
religion and by true philosophy and by
sophisticated serious thinking
and now they're having those questions
answered by radical leftist ideologues
who are extremely shallow in their
thought and who are leading them down a
very bad path
and telling them actually all you all
you are
is
your appetites
all you are
is either your flesh or not your flesh
all you they're they're not getting very
good answers there and we and
young people have a right to the truth
and we ought to present it to them in
schools
it's very hard not only is it hard
because the teacher unions keep
true things out of the classroom
but it's hard to teach people when
everyone is muzzled up
and
the the masking in schools shows no
signs of going away the head of the
teacher union the national teacher union
uh randy weingarten just went on msnbc
she was asked hey hold on when when are
you going to let the kids stop muzzling
themselves we all saw that picture of
stacy abrams the other day where stacey
abrams shows up she's smiling grinning
ear to ear but she forces all the kids
to be masked around her which has always
been the case the democrats don't follow
their own mass rules but they force
everyone else to and they whine and
complain and punish you if you violate
them one set of rules for me another one
for thee
and so in the wake of this weingarten
has asked when are the kids going to be
able to take the masks off
she says in very
clever political speak she basically
says no time soon
what dr mcbride just told us about mass
not particularly being effective for
children what's the argument against
taking off masks in schools well the
argument is that you have well let me
just say this
i am in favor of an off-ramp on mass
right the real issue becomes
are is the is
is the spread
low enough
so that there's no dissemination or
transmission in schools and it's not
the teachers transmitting to kids
it's more kids
and kids particularly in elementary
schools right now and so the question
really becomes
do we have that's why i like what
massachusetts has done because what
they've said is that on a
school-by-school basis they said if
there's 80 percent vaccination rates
then those schools can lift the mandates
okay so by the end she gives you a
little hope she says well look here's
something in the school set and i think
this is kind of nice you know once we
have 80 vaccination then likely will be
able to lift the mandates but that's not
the criterion that she
insists on right it's she's using the 80
as an example but what she actually says
is
well we're going to take the masks away
when there's no transmission
and then she sort of insinuates that
well if we get 80 vaccination then then
probably we'll have no transmission
except except we won't
except we know from dr fauci and
rachelle belensky and joe biden now and
all of all of the medical
experts and politicians who had
previously told us that the covet
vaccines would stop
transmission of the virus we now know it
doesn't stop transmission
so you can get the 80 vaccination it's
still gonna be transmitted kovid's just
here
it's like saying well we're gonna we're
gonna go back to school we're gonna take
the masks off when there's zero flu
you mean zero there's never gonna be
zero flu
and so
according to weingarten's own logic
the kids are never taking the masks off
until we force the issue until we go in
and we wield political power and we say
no
i don't care what you say weingarten i
don't care what you say teachers i don't
care what you say administrators
we're going to do this we are going to
have a say in our kids education first
and in our local communities and in our
national government
i remind you before we go
get your congressman to co-sponsor the
michael knowles federal health
protection pledge
house concurrent resolution 71
co-sponsor it right now
we'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
[Music]
i'm
so sorry
now
sorry
[Music]
jessica
i can smell the weakness from here
owes me money
let me out please
what good is this doing now
your daughter
she's very pretty
[Music]
[Music]